[Music]
what has been the consequence of that
well the first consequence was wild
sexual experimentation and why not what
would you expect it's like all of a
sudden reproductions under control does
that mean that women can be as
promiscuous as men well maybe that's
what it means we don't know so that was
part of the big 60s experiment and it
isn't obviously obvious that that went
particularly well it certainly led to
the pornographer keishon of our society
which i think is I really think is
actually quite dreadful
maybe that's my innate prudishness but I
don't know it seems to me that
pornography demeans the participants as
well as the viewers there's something
second-rate and furtive about it and I
think that everybody who engages in it
knows that it's it's it's it's an it's a
substitute for the real adventure of
life and I do think that it leads to a
certain kind of perhaps contempt it
leads to contempt I would say I mean I
don't ever think and you guys can ask
yourself this question I mean have you
ever met anybody who can finished
masturbating and then was proud about it
and who stood up straighter because of
it but you felt that they've really
conquered life as a consequence I mean I
just don't believe that that's the that
that's the the general post masturbation
feeling I don't believe that I believe
that it's it's it's it's like it's it's
something you do when you when you don't
have the right thing to do
and it's an admission that you're a
second-rate player essentially something
like that
so the pornographer keishon was a bad
thing